bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous on l'a entendu de
revers électoraux pour le parti d'être
cédés ou mais vraiment une défaite à
titre personnel pour angela merkel
bon c'est évidemment un échec pour la
céder ou mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit un échec personnel pour madame
angela merkel pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'elle a quitté la
présidence de la ceni où il ya deux ans
et demi en mettant une succession en
place l'actuelle ministre de la défense
a fait un intérim et maintenant il ya un
nouveau président de la cds où est donc
le deuxième successeur de madame merkel
et puis la deuxième raison c'est que en
réalité hier il s'agissait de quoi il
s'agissait de deux élections régionales
très importantes bien sûr de régions qui
sont proches de la france proche de
l'alsace et les gens tout simplement ont
réélu l'administration qui était au
pouvoir dans ces deux régions
et ce n'est pas rien parce que dans les
länder le le gouvernement local a
beaucoup de pouvoir par exemple il a
d'après la constitution
c'est lui qui a le pouvoir en matière de
santé c'est lui qui a le pouvoir en
matière d'éducation
alors eh bien en effet au
bade-wurtemberg on a réélu le
ministre-président puisque cela
s'appelle comme ça qui est inverse qui
est au pouvoir depuis dix ans de mandat
pour montrer sa flexibilité
il ad'ailleurs gouverner pendant cinq
ans avec le socialiste et puis pendant
cinq années avec la cdu ou donc les cinq
dernières années avec la cdu ou est en
effet la cd ou a fait un mauvais score a
perdu trois ou quatre points de
pourcentage
et puis dans l'autre dans le nord est
rhénanie palatinat et bien là on a une
femme qui est ministre présidente et qui
aussi a bien géré sa région et par
conséquent les électeurs ont été réélus
alors là la cd ou est dans l'opposition
de toute manière puisque le gouvernement
est un gouvernement
recall or comme on dit en allemagne
puisqu'il y a les socialistes qui hélas
l'abbaye sera présidente
il y a les verts et il y a
les le fdp c'est à dire les libéraux que
l'on considère comme orange et rouge
vert orange comme les feux de la
circulation dit-on également en
allemagne
alors bien sûr la situation se résume
par un avertissement sans frais pour
pour le parti cd ou mais je ne pense pas
que ce soit un désaveu de madame merkel
elle-même pour toutes les raisons que je
viens d'indiquer simplement on retient
en effet comme ça vient détruits dans
votre sujet il ya une autre hypothèse
que la grande coalition actuelle à
berlin et l'autre hypothèse pourrait
être un gouvernement tricolore comme
pour le nord rhénanie palatinat avec des
avec des une alliance du spd des
libéraux et des verts
on est encore pas là alors on l'aura
compris la course à la chancellerie est
bel et bien lancée qui a le plus de
chances d'être le prochain ou la
prochaine
une chancelière alors si tu enlèves ou
comme vous le dites prochain prochaine
puisque les verts n'ont pas encore
désigné leurs candidats et qu' ils
auront à choisir entre un député qui est
un universitaire jeune avec beaucoup de
charisme et puis une candidate qui elle
aussi est député et il y aura donc un
candidat vert
peut-être que la poussée fera que les
verts arrivent en tête
ça n'est pas sûr pour ce qui est de la
cd ou et bien logiquement c'est le
président qui a été désigné au mois de
janvier delà de la cd ou qui devrait
porter les couleurs de la cd ou pour les
élections du 26 septembre prochain ça
n'est pas absolument certain parce que
il a un opposant à l'intérieur de la
confédération c'est deus ex ou qui est
le président de la csu parti bavarois
mais qui est plus conservateur que lui
par conséquent il ya moins de capacité à
faire alliance avec d'autres partis
or on ne peut gouverner à berlin qu'avec
une coalition par conséquent il faut
avoir des capacités de conclure des
alliances et on verra en effet si le
prochain chancelier
ou la prochaine sur se lièrent et du
parti vert écologistes du parti
socialiste du spd ou bien de la cd ou cs
où il est encore trop tôt pour le dire
la chancelière en tout cas a dit
clairement qu'elle exclue et de faire un
cinquième mandat
et comme c'est une scientifique après
tout les spécialistes de la physique des
particules et elle a évalué ses chances
elle a aussi évalué son parcours et elle
considère qu'elle doit maintenant
s'arrêter alors l'allemagne à la grande
élection du bundestag en septembre la
france élections présidentielles en 2022
quelle sera la future relation entre
l'allemagne et la france
chaque fois qu'un changement de
chancelier août chancelière en allemagne
à chaque fois qu'un changement de
président de la république en france
cela se traduit par une période
d'ajustement par une période où on se
comprend moins bien mais finalement les
intérêts communs sont tellement
importants que après cette période
d'ajustement
eh bien la france et l'allemagne
s'assoient pour retrouver des positions
communes et pour réduire leurs
différends
spontanément bien sûr les intérêts
peuvent être divergents mais en réalité
les intérêts supérieurs étant beaucoup
plus important et convergents eh bien on
finit toujours par trouver une solution
alors il y aura également un troisième
élément dans le premier semestre de
l'année 2000
22 c'est que la présidence tournante de
l'union européenne
pendant ce semestre et bien c'est à la
france qu'il exercera et par conséquent
le président de la république française
prépare déjà le lancement de cette
présidence le 1er janvier prochain et il
la prépare avec madame merkel il la
prépare à avec le sucesseur ou la
successeure de madame merkel
et puis on verra bien ce qui se passera
à l'élection présidentielle française
mais la france est un état de droit qu'à
une unis l'administration à système
politique suffisamment solides pour que
quel que soit le résultat des élections
présidentielles en france
eh bien la france exerce normalement sa
présidence pendant les six mois au
conseil à bruxelles
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales